hello lovely people it is time for sonic
central
last year when i was watching this i was
in a hotel room in australia locked in
quarantine for two weeks and my mods
reminded me that sonic central last year
made me um cry from laughter i couldn't
handle
the i think it was olympics
anyway sonic frontier i watched a little
bit of that recently and was not into it
at all so maybe we'll see a little bit
more of that here
i'm not sure let's do it
it also is weird to me now how close
that
sonic flash sega opening sound is to
switch
[Music]
welcome everyone to sonic central hello
my name is ivo griskovich and i'm here
with the zookasan
for a look at all the upcoming
excitement in the world of sonic
last year we sell you imagine being the
anniversary of everyone's favorite such
a well-known ip that you get your own
conference annually
and now this year pokemon has come a lot
but still
sonic's just one guy we saw the
incredible success of sonic the hedgehog
2 which open is the number one movie
globally i didn't see it
thanks to all of you
that's right we could not have diet
without you and everyone's love and
support for sonic on behalf of the sonic
team and sega family i like the person a
lot all of you
and now let's see what the rest of the
year holds in store for the blue blur
breeze they enjoy
thank you i appreciate that i'll try the
games that defined a generation roll
back to the games that started it all
with sonic origins a new collection
including the definitive editions of
four iconic sonic titles but all the
sonic games i feel like are still pretty
accessible at least the ones that i
generally intend to play
i changed my mind i'm not very happy
about it because that's good music
like
you can play this game
[Music]
on a browser i've played it as like a
flash game
still slaps still slaps still holds up
[Music]
look at him man he just he goes so fast
you know
[Music]
i still think the fact that tails flies
arse up is very funny
[Music]
[Music]
it's a little this is i'm a little i
realized i tuned out even though i'm
being recorded because you're showing me
things i've already seen
mirror mode's cool i guess
i just feel like maybe this should be a
little bit short
cool though it's cool
[Music]
fully remastered and redefined
experience all sonic origins has to
offer happy birthday next month on june
23rd that's as they said it's his
birthday
wow
wow
okay
i still have introduced a little
concept of what roblox is and i know i
should like ciao and is using their life
force to power up metal sonic
exclusively for sonic central unlock amy
ciao using a designated code
free the electric chow and reprogram
metal is this gonna be like a normal
thing that we get now fight against
eggman on june 11. in roblox
this summer damn special movie themed
characters from sonic the hedgehog 2 in
both sonic forces and sonic dash
in november super shadow is joining the
battle
this halloween watch out for my phyllis
the dark that's actually pretty sick
your greatest achievements with player
banners
in sonic dash and also in sonic dash
plus on apple arcade
the new netflix animated series sonic
prime is coming soon
here is a sneak peek of i think i
actually will watch it like out of
curiosity sonic central i will i will
watch it
but i don't know if it's a kid's show or
not
because like cuphead is brilliant
obviously arcane is
it brilliant or may not be
some more video game shows to be excited
about i always feel weird saying it but
obviously i'm excited about the last of
us
just because
i work at sony
next please welcome the voice of sonic
from the sonic movie with a sneak peek
of sonic the hedgehog 2. wait wait wait
wait wait blue ray oh i was like this
movie did come out already right okay
hey everybody ben schwartz here i am the
voice of sonic the hedgehog please hold
your applause please check out the home
entertainment release of my movie sonic
2.
beyond it being another great adventure
for sonic this isn't coming to streaming
anyways let's do this
yeah it is loaded with a ton of great
extras
it's got deleted scenes soon what did
you put in the coffee
can you hitler hilarious bloopers
he had beans in his hair tons of fun
moments from behind the scenes on set
and to top it off an exclusive animated
short which takes place right after the
events of sonic 2. that's cool voiced by
yours truly ben schwartz let's see how
fast
so do me a favor let's break down that
chili dog and take a look
right now or soon similar tuna
yeah i don't know if it's streaming
somewhere
wow face masks this is weird this is a
weird conference
straight from angel island isn't it
g-fuel what's inspired
level up your xbox gaming experience
with this sonic the hedgehog wireless
controller pretty cool quick charging
stand by razer and do you like the
charging stand this summer
more art introduces beautiful new art
handmade silk screen prints are a
celebration of the sonic titan man
hand screened introducing hype and sonic
the hedgehog capsule collection okay
that's dope featuring energetic designs
inspired by the high octane speedster
himself
damn check out the upcoming collectibles
first four figures i love basketball
and miles tails that's interesting i've
never seen them shown in three days ago
and knuckles are now available as fast
showcase your controller or just how
that's cool too between gaming
check out the newest cable guy
controller holder
[Music]
retro gaming enthusiasts and sonic fans
find these iconic early 90s aesthetic
inspired statues very cute
thanks from japan is a special sonic
soft vinyl
nobody else does conferences like this
like this is just so strange
okay thank you
it means a lot the music ooh cool
stay tuned for the return of the sonic
the hedgehog symphony that is cool
relive the magic of the sonic 30th
anniversary symphony concert live and in
person
i would love to honestly iconic moments
from sonic's history come to life on the
big screen i will 100 do that symphony
orchestra
with a few new surprises in store
oh brazil game show i'd love to go there
one day i bet it's awesome brazilian
fans are so intense in the coolest way
i'd love to go info coming soon
yeah i'm down i love a live video game
play on all platforms
coming to fall guys
sonic and tails
they can't keep doing this to sonic he
can't keep shape shifting this much
it's too much
oh my god
oh my god that's ridiculous we are
excited oh yes please i would like to
see it new animated special oh featuring
knuckles and taking place before the
events of the game i was expecting
gameplay we hope you enjoy this
exclusive first look this is an animated
short that we're just having inside this
conference okay
maybe i'll give context to the
environment i'll take that i felt like
it was very weird
we look forward to what entire short
later this year oh okay sonic frontiers
that was weird i don't even really know
why you did that
this is what i would like to see i would
like to see this
i would like this please
i thought it looked so good when they
revealed it
because this should be like not the tech
demo anything that we saw where it was
just clearly like a reporter kind of
exploring an open world we should
actually get
see this does look cool that looks cool
that is [ __ ] cool
finally some enemies
okay
not quite as long as i would have hoped
but that was advanced want to see more
of sonic frontiers yes then be sure to
visit ign.com right now and all june
long because sonic frontiers is the ign
first cover story you can watch the
world exclusive gameplay reveal right
now as well as the first ever hands-on
preview
uploads some later in the month maybe i
should check that out with the sonic
frontiers development team and more you
gotta go fast to ign
nice congrats ign
sonic frontiers is on its way there's
more details to come so be sure to
follow us on the official social
channels in the video description below
thank you for tuning in to sonic's very
this was weird this the whole thing was
very weird um i had fun
but uh
i don't really have a lot of words
either
maybe it's that i'm not enough of a
sonic fan i am a very casual sonic
enjoyer
maybe you have to be a hardcore sonic
fan to really enjoy your average sonic
central i don't know
it just felt weird this kind of felt
like a fifa dream i don't know